the European Union has announced
sanctions on Iran's Security Forces over
the death of the 22-year-old woman Gina
Masa amini last month and the repression
of subsequent anti-government protests
EU foreign ministers agreed to Target
Iran's so-called morality police and
whose hands amini died as well as a
cabinet minister overseeing internet
blockages the named officials will be
subject to EU Visa bans and asset
freezes
support for the protesters and
condemnation of the brutal Crackdown EU
diplomats gathered in Luxembourg to send
a strong message to Iran's leadership
today we are making a clear that we are
taking those responsible who use brutal
force against citizens against women
against men against teenagers just
because they want to live their life as
we do and freedom and peace
for more than a month now Iran's leaders
have struggled to contain protests
sparked by the death of Gina Maxa amini
after she was arrested by the so-called
morality police the protest quickly
morphed into anti-government
demonstrations activists say some 200
people have been killed
announcing the new sanctions they use
foreign policy chief called on Iran to
end the violence adding that if
necessary the block will go further
the council adopted today restrictive
measures against 11 individuals
on four entities
targeting those linked to the death of
my shamini
and to the repression of peaceful
protesters
and if needed
we are ready to add more names to this
list
Iran has vowed an immediate response to
the new sanctions
such rushed and biased behavior is
unacceptable it's meddling in our
domestic affairs we don't accept this
as politicians trade accusations
protesters like these students in
central Iran continue venting their
anger at the authorities who seem
unwilling to listen
and for more we can speak to gisio Nia
she's the director of the Atlantic
council's strategic litigation project
focused on accountability for human
rights violations her area of expertise
is rule of law in Iran Miss Mia what do
you make of these new EU sanctions what
effect if any do you think they'll have
well it's certainly a welcome
development these sanctions on 15
Iranian entities and individuals who are
implicated in human rights violations
including Iran's morality police and its
law enforcement forces it's very
appreciated because this is the only
second such set of Human Rights
designations
um that the EU has levied against the
Islamic Republic since 2013.
so human rights lawyers and Advocates
have long been calling for further
designations for human rights violations
on top Iranian leadership and that just
hadn't happened until now
are there other levers you would like
the International Community to pull to
hold the Iranian government accountable
yes there's a lot that the International
Community can be doing right now and
that the EU and its individual member
states can be doing
um one is that member states need to
immediately call a special session of
the UN Human Rights Council there needs
to be a special session to discuss the
ongoing human rights crisis in Iran and
to discuss the setup of an
accountability mechanism that will allow
for a repository to streamline the
collection and preservation of evidence
of violations and to possibly issue
reports on the situation so that is
something that the International
Community and U.N member states can do
today if they wanted to an additional
thing that they could do is remove the
Islamic Republic Iran of Iran from the
UN Commission on the status of women
which is the un's top women's rights
body they were elected last year year
and they started a four-year term in
March 2022 they're going to be there
until 2026.
um a country which has gender
discriminatory laws on the books to the
severity that the Islamic Republic does
should not be allowed to have a leader
leadership position on a U.N body like
that
the traditional thing that can happen
yeah sorry sorry continue
I was going to say additional thing that
could happen with respect to these
sanctions so we saw that there are these
human rights sanctions that have been
issued
um
it's fine to freeze the assets of the
individuals who are implicated in these
violations and who are responsible for
them but I also think that EU countries
should start considering legislation
that allows for the seizure of these
assets of chronic human rights violators
and transfer from perpetrators to
victims similar to what Canada has done
they recently passed legislation that
allows for that repurposing of assets
yeah these protests have been going on
for over a month now and despite the
deadly Crackdown they don't appear to be
abating I want to look ahead with you
what is your sense of how this is going
to play out
the Islamic Republic of Iran has
successfully squelched out previous
protests that have been reoccurring in
the country since December 2017. I think
what is different here is that young
girls young women have joined these
protests it this is about social change
they have joined by taking off their
mandatory hijab and peacefully
protesting for their rights I think it
becomes much more difficult for State
security forces to kill young girls
girls as young as 12 who are protesting
for their rights so that's why we see
these protests enduring and really
because the core is it's about social
change they are demanding social
freedoms yeah specifically with regard
to the fire in the Evan prison where
many protesters are being held what are
you hearing about what's happening there
and how concerned are you about the
welfare of the prisoners
well we've been hearing different things
Iranian State media and the Judiciary
first reported that 40 people were
killed in the fire then they quickly
revised that number to four now they're
saying that eight people have died
because an additional Force succumbed to
their injuries so we don't have a
transparent death count human rights
organizations and citizen journalist
collectives are trying to establish the
welfare of different individuals but we
should remember that there are lots of
political prisoners and Evin there are
human rights lawyers there are those who
are in prison just for their peaceful
expression of their freedom of
expression Association and assembly and
just for doing their jobs so
um this is very critical the prison is
overcrowded right now because the
authorities have rounded up a lot of
different Civil Society leaders there
and this really demands the
international community's attention and
anybody you know and any countries that
have diplomatic relations with the
Islamic Republic should be urging the
absolute welfare and release of these
prisoners okay Sonia with the Atlantic
Council thank you so much
thank you